[Music]
over speech with the culmination of the
fiercest show of solidarity amongst some
of the most powerful women in Hollywood
and it all converged on her ET platform
it's like the meeting of all the power
brokers hello ladies hello to be in the
room where it happens can I tell you how
happy I am for you and excited for you
time's up co-founders and newly pregnant
stars Eva Longoria and America Ferrera
were Reese Witherspoon and Natalie
Portman's plus one for a cause America
hopes these efforts lead to a better
world for the next generation all the
more reason to get to work and try and
make the changes that we know we need to
make in our culture in our society we
have a deadline I have daughters like I
don't want this stuff happened when
you're just trying to make your dream
happen Best Actress nominee Michelle
Williams arrived with me to movement
founder Toronto birth I thought that I
would have to raise my daughter to learn
how to protect yourself and defend
herself against the world and what I've
realized is that we can hand our
daughters a different world it's very
very beautiful and exciting and saying
that time is up in the weeks leading up
to the awards gal gadot joined the other
wonder women in Hollywood in getting the
word out so far the movement has raised
over 16 million dollars to help victims
of workplace harassment have you ladies
just been on the phone for like the last
three weeks calling everyone yes it's
been like four four we have four
full-time jobs and three of them were
times up Reese Witherspoon Jessica
Chastain I mean they have been wonderful
leaders I'm proud of you
few conversations with Kerry Washington
and we were to second with the whole
thing and even can the music business we
haven't even touched that doll maximum
would approve Nicole I don't know what
it is but I think I need to be a
consultant when it's time to talk about
that
[Music]